hi friends today I am sitting down with
Michael kazoo who is the CEO and founder
of brute strength training and two times
CrossFit Games team champion he is also
the man behind Brooke ence Jacob hat nur
Kara Webb and the winning team from us
J's CrossFit Games - Wow such brutes
what makes his story so compelling is
the fact that he does not come from what
you would consider to be the typical
perfect environment for an elite athlete
or a fantastic businessman he's an ex
drug and alcohol addict he's been a
rehab a number of times it is apparent
that he has suffered with some really
dark places in his life and yet he's
managed to come out the other side and
be this incredibly well-balanced very
altruistic very shrewd intelligent and
compassionate guy who also has an
unbelievable capacity as an athlete and
as a coach it's definitely one of the
best conversations that I've had I found
it incredibly empowering a lot of the
conversation isn't about sport its to do
with his approach for how to mentally
overcome obstacles within your life he's
been to a stage where he was smoking
heroin and injecting cocaine which I
didn't even know that you could do and
out of the other side of that he's got
this fantastic life where he's
flourishing and he's doing something
they really cares about and is well
regarded within his field it was a
wonderful chat and I feel incredibly
fortunate to have been able to sit down
with him so that's enough for intros
here he is the man himself mr. Michael
[Music]
so mr. Michael cashew welcome to modern
wisdom thanks for having me brother I'm
excited yeah me too me too
so CEO of brute strength 2 times
CrossFit Games winner and all-around
good guy how are you doing today doing
great man other than the fact that my
water got shut off they sent me they
sent me like three warnings but I
thought it was all spam so I just threw
them away
and today they shut it off and my wife's
family is in town so we're we're having
to use the bathroom and stuff no way
house that's pretty funny that's funny
well I think it's a great day though
yeah
so Howard self to give a little bit of
background I think pretty much everybody
in the CrossFit community will have
heard of brute strength brute body in
one form or another but I think it would
be interesting for you to give us a
little bit of a background as to what
you did as an athlete when you were
younger I know that you said that you
did a lot of sports when you were
younger
so if you could try and just give us a
little bit of background to begin with
that'd be great yeah I I grew up playing
as many sports as possible I play
football baseball soccer basketball golf
I did powerlifting weightlifting and I
was above average at all of them kind of
naturally but I never applied myself at
all I loved competing I love playing
games and I just didn't see the value
and practicing as a kid so you know and
I never really developed much in in my
younger years in high school until right
before I left for Utah I started I
started to see that if I practice hard I
would get better at hitting I would get
you know better as an outfielder and I
started to practice really hard and then
I moved away and took a couple years off
of sports but yeah I was very active
loved sports and was just not a not a
very hard worker yeah which is
interesting when you manage to make it
to the elite in a sport as well as
appose it's an interesting dichotomy so
the other day I had dominick mcgregor
who's the CEO of social chain and he was
very candid
about his problems that he'd had with
substances and I think it's very
humbling and quite eye-opening to see
stories firsthand of people that you
operating at such a high level but I've
also had such problems that serious
problems that would break a lot of a lot
of people's spirits and yet they're
still able to perform a level that most
people would consider to be they've made
it up the hierarchy and and you know
they're really successful could you take
us through your problems with substances
and and how that came about and then
sort of where that where that took you
where you ended up what do you mean what
what problems were substances if you you
just matter with you yeah and I'll start
out by saying it was because it broke my
spirit that I was that I've been able to
have the success that I have it's
because I went so low and so deep that I
have the ability to be so grounded and
be so passionate about you know the
different things that I am passionate
about today my the the journey kind of
started at nine years old I had my first
drink of alcohol by myself
on my ninth birthday and I remember
taking a shot of whiskey and just
feeling like maybe for the first time
that I was accepted and feeling really
comfortable in my body I didn't realize
until much much later that I was a very
anxious kid and I wanted everyone wants
to be liked everyone wants to be cool I
really really had to be liked and I had
to be cool and I was willing to go to
much greater lengths than my peers to be
accepted by the time I was 14 I was
smoking weed very you know very
regularly at my house by myself every
single day that led to pain killers and
benzodiazepines I was taking that those
every single day as a fifteen-year-old
around that time my parents started to
catch wind of what what I was doing I
started to fail you know drug test for
for just about every drug on the panel
and so they started taking me
to a a meetings as a fifteen-year-old
Wow and I remember sitting in there and
really really feeling for these people
you know these are people that were
either homeless or they had lost their
families or they had gotten some kind of
severe illness you know alcoholics very
very chronic really yeah exactly like
really bad liver issues and I really
developed some empathy for these people
but I wasn't one of them you know I I'm
gonna guess the one very many of the 15
year olds that were in AAA meetings
there were none there were none and so I
thought that I didn't belong there yep
and I really got nothing out of it for
myself I was in complete denial that I
had any problem I just thought I was
having fun and I was in complete control
by the time I was 16 I was using ecstasy
and cocaine and very very serious
painkillers but you still go into the
AAA meetings at this time still going to
AAA meetings and actually I started to
go more frequently and I started I
started to have these kind of different
lives where I would go to AAA meetings
probably two or three nights a week and
then another two nights a week I would
tell my parents I was going to a meeting
but I would just go get loaded but I
really and I this doesn't have a ton to
do with my story but I think it's really
interesting and I think it's really
interesting I started to have this
different life where I started to
develop these true friendships with with
these people naa people that were
roughly 10 years older than me that
would that I just learned a ton from
they were they were much more mature
than any of my friends they they cared
about a lot of different things they
were really happy and carefree they were
having a shitload of fun completely
sober and I loved that
and I and I made some good friends out
of it and I was high a lot of the time
that I was hanging out with them you
know there was there was I was still in
complete denial that I had any problem
with it I thought I just had to convince
all of the authority figures that I had
it under control or that I wasn't using
drugs and that it would all be
okay you just playing the game just
playing the game I'm a great great
player of the game by the time I was 17
the first one of my good friends passed
away he he went to sleep next to another
one of my friends they both took oxy
cotton and xanax that night and one of
my friends woke up and the other didn't
and instead of going to this guy's
funeral I chose to shoot up oxy cotton
and cocaine for the first time and that
that really shows you that kind of
person that I had become I just I didn't
care for other people I started to steal
from every single person in my life my
peers my family businesses know no one
and nothing was off-limits I just
thought I was entitled to whatever you
had waiting old from everyone what do
you think that was born from where do
you think the this detachment from
responsibilities came from that's a
really great question
I think it I think it just started kind
of as a seed where I made one decision
that lets take I can't I I definitely
can't remember the first the first time
this ever happened but I'll say I
started the first time I ever stole it
was out of my mom's purse and it was
probably something like five or ten
dollars to get a couple pills or maybe a
dime bag and I just I didn't see it as
that big of a deal I saw it definitely
didn't line up with my values that I had
been raised on but I didn't think my mom
would really miss the money I thought if
she doesn't find out you know no real
harm done I'm not gonna do it again yeah
and it's just a small the small lie like
a small wrong yep and so it didn't seem
like that that big of a deal it happened
again
and it happened again and sooner or
later I start doing slightly bigger
thing slippery slope
exactly slightly bigger things I start
stealing from other people and I just
start making these compromises where I'm
ding out of line with my values and I'm
not just like someone losing weight
can't really see themselves losing the
weight I couldn't really see myself
changing because it happened so slowly
and over such a long period of time yeah
so it was just one compromise after the
other I understand
so 17 friends died and you detached away
from that then what happens why'd you go
from that February later that year in
February my parents chose to send me to
rehab and I absolutely needed it and I
even knew that I needed it at this point
I knew that I was just I was just really
out of control and I was kind of scaring
myself with some of the decisions I was
making I knew you know this guy had just
died earlier that year I had totaled the
truck I had gone gone through four lanes
of oncoming traffic and totaled the
truck and so I was kind of scaring
myself and I knew I needed it but I
thought I had just read the book scar
tissue by Anthony Kiedis and in that
book he goes through like I don't know
half a dozen short stint rehab centers
like 30 days and they're all in Malibu
and he talks about like meeting meeting
some fine chicks and stuff so I'm kind
of pumped yeah I'm going it sounds like
a holiday yeah I think I'm going to a
cush rehab center I might meet some
chicks
yeah and I'll kind of I'll just regain
control over myself
that's that's my thought process my
parents had a totally different idea
they sent me to not a let's see nine
nine or 11 months of inpatient treatment
a couple different facilities and then I
did another nine months of a halfway
house and that was it was absolutely
crucial and it transformed my life how
so the first two months were in a
wilderness therapy center and it was in
the middle of the desert with 15 other
adolescent boys and really what that
time did was it helped me to
it helped all of that chatter in my head
you know I had some depression and
anxiety and my mind was just chaotic and
it helped that to really chill out it
helped me to detach from a lot of the
bad influences in my life it helped me
to detach from a lot of my my desires
and just that that internal chatter that
never turned off I didn't really get
much good therapy done there that
started in the next program so this was
a like a lockdown facility you don't
leave for several months at all and I
had a very hard-nosed therapist that
called me on my [ __ ] and this treatment
center in general really encouraged the
the a lot of the therapy to be done by
the peers and again going back to me
just really wanting to be liked and
accepted that was by far the most
powerful thing is that's not what
positive influence exactly yeah and I
mean they had guys just saying I would I
would be thinking I'm sharing something
really vulnerable and I'm being
authentic and they would flat-out call
me out like that's that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're telling us like five
percent of the truth passing it off as
the full truth yeah and man I just I I
had to learn to go deep for a long time
I just completely shut down and I
refused and I withdrew which is kind of
my that was my MO if things got tough I
would just withdraw at some point I got
over that and I really did the work I
got vulnerable I contributed to other
people's recovery and I accepted other
people to hold me accountable to love me
and I just learned a shitload of lessons
man and it really changed my life that's
fantastic so I definitely think that it
makes sense you'd absconded from
responsibility for your own actions a
little bit and you were obviously able
to outwit some of the people in your
life that were questioning whether or
not you are actually being truthful and
I think that a lot of people can
probably relate to that it doesn't
necessarily need to be with regard to
drugs but vulnerability with a partner
telling them that you actually don't
feel comfortable with that guy or girl
that they're talking to or whatever and
it manifests itself in another way in
resentment or in level of mistrust or
whatever it might be and I think that
there's a lot of people that will
withdraw in that way play the game up
until the point at which the the
problems out of the way and then they
can kind of get cracking again on their
terms without actually having to make
himself vulnerable so I think that's an
extreme example of a situation that a
lot of people probably go through so
you're nine months deep now you've gone
through you're nine to eleven months of
rehab and then where are we then I start
college I go to a halfway house and
immediately after I get out of that
inpatient treatment I'm rockin and
rollin man I'm so motivated just so high
on life I start running for the first
time and real quick I try it out for the
University of Utah baseball team
couldn't quite hack it so I start
running and I train really really hard
for the Salt Lake City Marathon and I
ended up winning my age division
no really well I'm pumped on it and at
the same time I get really burnt burn
out on running so at the end of that I
suddenly don't have like a physical goal
and I also didn't have many friends yet
I was in a in a new city for the first
time and a lot of the people in my
halfway house were actually you know
smoking crack and drinking and it was
just not a very positive environment so
you've gone back to maybe a negative
influence from the paid group again well
I just didn't hang out with them at all
okay okay so you've learned that you can
segment your life a little bit
absolutely and I was I was definitely
gung-ho on staying sober and I started
to meet some friends through Alcoholics
Anonymous and Narcotics Anonymous but I
didn't make any real deep connections in
the first six months and so when that
when that marathon was done didn't have
a goal and I just I had really started
to isolate myself
just because I didn't have anything to
really look forward to I didn't like
college at all I did I didn't have any
deep relationships and suddenly I don't
have this physical goal and I was always
really driven by physical goals even if
it just be playing games really hard
right I I always loved to play and it
didn't have any of that and so long
story short I isolate myself for about a
month start smoking cigarettes again
kind of get caught well not kind of I
get really sick I get a really bad cold
because I smoked one of my sponsors my
AAA sponsors like roll your own
cigarettes and it's really harsh and so
I get sick and man this seed of a
thought gets planted in my head where
I've gotten kind of depressed didn't
have any good friends and this just seed
of a thought pops in maybe I can go get
loaded right I can go get some codeine
syrup and I can get loaded and it won't
be a big deal and I push it away and I
actually I talked to my sponsor about it
I talked to my therapist even about it
and I decided I'm not gonna do it
but that seed of a thought grows really
really rapidly because I'm still sick
and it just it feels really shitty and
I'm depressed it grows really rapidly
and within a week or two I decided that
I was gonna get [ __ ] up and within 24
hours I made the decision that I was
gonna go to the hospital the University
Hospital I was gonna get some codeine
syrup and I knew that I could lie to the
doctor and say I was in a lot of back
pain because I was born with a genetic
back disorder and so that's what I did
I went to the University Hospital got
the got the drugs got in the elevator of
the pharmacy with the drugs and by the
time I reached the bottom floor I had
taken a bunch of pills took a big ol sip
of coffee syrup yeah probably eight
hours later I'm smoking crack and
shooting heroin all over again and
you've tumbled straight back in yep
luckily for me
that lap that only lasted a week and
some people in my halfway house told my
therapist that I was using again and
they and they pulled me back into the
program and that I think it was June
maybe 28th 2008 or the last day that I
used heroin or smoked crack okay and
then was that from there is that full
sobriety from that date for five years I
was completely sober and a but yeah
roughly five years later I made the
decision to drink occasionally and smoke
weed occasionally and how have you found
that effect on full sobriety and what a
lot of people attach their their
recovery to is being teetotal and yes
it's all or nothing and it definitely
sounds like that's a theme in your life
as well I did a podcast not so long ago
I brought this up with Dom with a friend
who said that he didn't believe that
going completely teetotal is conquering
an addiction he said as far as he's
concerned it's being able to stop your
use of the substance and then the
reintroduction of the substance on your
terms or a substance there's some that
are too difficult to be able you can't
have a little bit of heroin but right
specifically with alcohol his point was
that it needs to be a reintroduction on
your terms and if you can then control
the usage so how did you find having
your first drink after you'd had such a
long time off and were you scared
we concerned that that was going to be
the beginning of something yeah worse
really really great question and I I
love what your friend Dom said and I
would agree to a certain point but
everyone's different and there are human
beings that I believe are so they've
they've used for so long and just
literally rewired their brains for so
many years it it's not even safe to ever
chance reintroducing anything
for me I thought that could be the case
and I thought about it for about six
months and talked to my entire support
system other than my parents because
that
really scared them but I talked to
everyone else therapists mentors friends
etc and then one night a friend came
over and he had a big bag of weed and he
went to the shower
and I've been thinking about it and so I
just grabbed this little this little
nugget and later that night I rolled
myself a joint and it was it was
impulsive of me right I couldn't say for
sure that nothing bad was gonna happen
but I had been thinking about it for so
long and I was pretty damn sure that I
had overcome the issues the challenges
that led me to the place that I was in
the first place and it felt really
confident and so I made the decision and
smoke some weed and nothing bad happened
and so it was it was really scary in the
beginning and I kept I kept kind of like
looking and waiting for things in my
mind to change like for me to develop
cravings and they just never came but
though the one promise that I made to
myself and I will always keep is that if
I feel any kind of emotion like negative
emotion any kind of real challenge in my
life I'm very vigilant that I can't
medicate with any kind of substance I
have to deal with it
healthily like a healthy human being by
doing some introspective work by sharing
it with someone I trust by just
literally working through it and I use I
use those things too as a you know to
have fun with people as a social event
not as a coping mechanism anymore I
understand I understand completely
were you proud of yourself refa
referentially after the event after you
had you first
spliff after you'd had your first drink
was there a sense of achievement that
you knew hang on this was something that
I used to like I was never able to clean
140 kilos and now I finally cleaned 140
kilos like was there a sense of
accomplishment having done it and then
not tumbled down the rabbit hole so to
speak no I was
it was a feeling of relief and a feeling
of guilt Wow because for a full year I
didn't tell my parents okay because I
decided and who know I don't know what
the right decision was but I felt so
much guilt because I knew if I told them
at a certain point they would be just so
terrified and I didn't want them to feel
that I wanted to get I wanted to have
done it for long enough to where I could
say hey I've been doing this for a year
I'm happier than I was before right
I've prioritized my mental health still
and I'm even happier and I just want I
want to let you guys know that I'm okay
but I've made this decision so I carried
that guilt with me for about a year
well that's a heavy burden to carry
especially when you know for sure
potentially using substances as well
even in moderation it's still a pretty
silly pretty big burden to boil sure it
was worth it to me though because one of
the biggest decisions I chose to not be
completely sober anymore was because I
felt like I was expending a lot of
energy trying to protect this this
sobriety that I didn't really identify
with anymore I didn't identify with this
sense of being powerless anymore so I
thought I was spending energy without
needing to means that make sense yeah
willpower is a finite resource there's a
interesting study by dr. Roy Baumeister
with radishes have you heard of this I
know I know of the concept powers finite
I don't know if I know of that study so
basically put two people in a room one
had radishes and cookies and the other
just had cookies the radishes group were
told that they could only eat the
radishes and the cookies group were
allowed to eat the cookies then after
they'd both been in the room for a fixed
period of time both groups were given a
tough mathematical test that I think
couldn't be completed within the
particular time frame it was a long time
frame the group that had the radishes
gave up 50% quicker than the group that
didn't know B that is fascinating
because their willpower had been reduced
already
so when it came doing a cognitively
demanding task they had nothing left in
the tank or their last [ __ ] less left in
the tank that's cool it is cool isn't it
I think it's um
it's a big we'll get on to in a second
but you're a big advocate of morning
routines and of taking things out of
choice and into habitual the habitual
domain and I think that that definitely
is if anyone who's listening that
doesn't have a good morning routine for
a start up like that that's all that you
need to know if you if you spend your
time in the morning choosing which
cereal it's gonna be or what meat you're
gonna cook or whether you do meditate or
don't meditate or do have a shower don't
have a shower that's a decision later in
the day that you need to make do you
can't you can't make with as much
efficiency so you're now clean CrossFit
how did you get into it and what was
your first ever workout can you remember
oh absolutely
so I had just run I had just run the
marathon and it was actually before I
relapsed my a guy who would then become
the best man at my wedding
you know what seven eight years later he
I met him through my chemical dependency
counselor the this gal knew that I you
know loved to be active and had didn't
have any friends so she hooked me up
with this guy Bryce and we started
snowboarding together he knew that I was
kind of looking for some kind of fitness
to do and he said hey man if you want
come come try this new thing I'm doing
and he said I was healthy CrossFit
2008-2009 nine nine so this is early
days so let's see mm yeah eight I think
it was nine so that would mean that
that's the that's the year that the
relapse happened so he he brings me in
and I'm thinking I'm in phenomenal shape
man just one my age bracket I'm gonna
kick everybody's ass and it was fight
gone bad
and I did one round as hard as I
possibly could and III halfway blacked
out from there come out that looks a
little bit quick exactly I was sore for
probably ten days after but I absolutely
loved it oh and I and I
came in dead last in the whole gym I was
not naturally gifted at CrossFit at all
so I just felt I fell in love with that
feel that transformation that happens
throughout that that hour-long class
right you get your your ass absolutely
kicked everyone's doing it together
everyone's suffering and giving all of
the effort that they can and on the
other side they come out a stronger
human being mentally right I loved I
loved that process and you know it I
said I did it for a couple weeks that
relapse happened and then I found it
again probably six months later okay so
the class is a bit of a microcosm for
you overcoming obstacles elsewhere I
suppose as well the classes go through
something that's difficult you come out
feeling better at the end I suppose
that's a theme that you'd been through
several times back and forth over the
years preceding that as well certainly
and I couldn't articulate that at the
time I just thought I thought it was a
great workout it was some it was very
positive people to be around and I just
loved being at that gem what had you
done before with regards to training
that was similar had you obviously
you've done sports that were athletic
but had you done anything in the way of
weightlifting or something similar to
that seriously I competed in
powerlifting a little bit I did a couple
weightlifting competitions and I grew up
my dad started bringing me to the gym
when I was probably eight and I did it I
didn't take it very seriously but at my
school I probably took it more seriously
than any other kid I not not because I
wanted to get better at the sports just
because I loved I love to lift weights
and feel like I was getting stronger I
loved the feeling of putting 135 on the
bench press for the first time 225 for
the first time it was just a it was just
a good feeling I like being in the gym
the addictive personalities showing
through a little bit as well I suppose
but not sure not know in a positive
light so how do you go from being dead
last in the gym obviously you've got
work capacity you've completed a
marathon so endurance wise I suppose
there's a good
there's the beginnings of being able to
grind it out but there's not very many
CrossFit workouts that take between two
and three hours so you know you've got
all right you've got some big holes in
your game what was when you were
starting out what what were you the
shittest uh what was really bad for you
honestly probably my strength because I
had I was really strong at one point in
high school but then I got really into
drugs and then I spent nearly two years
without touching a weight and so
everything was heavy for me and I I
wasn't even someone that took to the
gymnastics techniques very quickly it
just took a lot of practice or anything
particularly easy running right okay so
if you've got if you've got some running
in it then you sweet and if not well at
the time at the time I'm a completely
different athlete now and I yeah just
like the running okay so tell me how you
get from there to being the the number
one team in CrossFit two years in a row
at the games what's the level of work
output that you needed to go through to
get yourself from that guy in the first
workout to standing on number one podium
at the games so for about a year I
didn't even hear I didn't even know that
like a competition like an official
CrossFit competition existed and so I
just showed up at the gym nearly every
single day and just went as hard as I
possibly could and I had a different
points I just had different people than
I was chasing right different levels of
people that I was chasing and I said if
I can beat that person then I'm getting
better and over the course of the year I
worked my way up to chasing the guy that
got the best time every single day his
name was Rob he became a really really
good friend of mine and I just started I
started chasing him and and
just putting in time in the gym yeah at
some point I started adding a little bit
of strength work before my workouts a
little bit further I was doing a little
bit of strength work and I was doing a
second metcon either right after the you
know workout of the day or I would come
in a second time to the gym and just put
in extra work in the same probably a
year after I think it's a full year
after I started I did a competition
where I competed against Tommy
hackenbruck who would later become my
teammate and I was beating him for long
enough in the day I was in first place
in this competition for long enough that
I really got his attention and he ends
up really kicking my ass because in the
beginning of the day there were no
strength events and so after that he he
just destroyed me but after that after
the event he comes up to me and Rob that
was at my gym and he said hey y'all are
both the other both great at this why
don't y'all come to my gym and we'll
start a team and so it was at that time
it felt like one of the hardest
decisions of my life to leave my first
gym yes it felt like I was breaking up
with my family but you know over the
course of a couple weeks I made the
decision to leave and that year we we
had a team that went to the games and
Tommy wasn't a part of it we had a team
that went to the games that place ninth
and that's the first time that I
followed a structured training program
we all just followed Tommy hackenbruck
training program okay and it was a lot
of twoa days there was some mono
structural work like running and rowing
but not a ton and I would actually skip
a lot of that and it was a you know that
was the first time that I really took it
seriously so would you say that that's a
lot in terms of sophistication the
programming that you were doing that
built the basis upon which most of your
work time was done in the build-up to
you winning the games how would you
compare that in terms of sophistication
to programming that both yourselves do
now and I guess what is typical within
the within the community at the moment
what is typical in the community I would
call it as sophisticated if not better
really the the guy that did it his name
is Rob McDonald he was the general
manager of Jim Jones for a long time he
has he's coached dozens of professional
athletes fighters NFL players NBA
players and he just really really gets
strength and conditioning at its core he
really understands the principles of
shrinking conditioning and he applied
all of the work that he's done with
professional athletes for so long and
just added a CrossFit twist to it with
with a little bit of Tommy's help yeah
so even in the infancy of the sport
you've got someone who's yes so far
ahead of the game and that was huge for
me I started to see I learned the the
correct way to train like really really
rapidly the the next year this is really
what what change for me and what had the
biggest impact for me is we decided that
we were gonna take the best people of
that team and we're and Tommy was gonna
join the team is he really in three at
this point is it three and through it
yeah exactly
we decided that we were going to try to
create a team that could go and win the
CrossFit Games and so we recruited
people and at that time people were
still talking about recruiting like it
was like it was a sin you know and I
just laughed I'm like this is every
single sport recruiting yeah there's
nothing absolutely nothing like
ethically wrong with recruiting we
literally got people from other gyms to
start working out at our gym yeah and we
got some savages and what changed for me
was seeing how a couple of my new
teammates trained specifically I'll talk
about Adrienne Conway who I still work
with to this day he did every single
thing on the program
he slept eight to nine hours a day his
diet was on point
he got body work done on him several
times a week every single thing was on
point and that's the first time I
closely observed someone training like a
professional and it inspired me to do
the same so he's not doing more and he's
also not doing less exactly yes doing
exactly what his coach is telling him to
which is what a professional does he's
doing everything that he can to set him
up for success and so I wasn't perfect
but I I got damn near close to doing the
exact same thing and it what did what it
did is it obviously it helped me
progress physically at a level I just
was not used to I got better at
everything very quickly but it just
changed my mind it changed my mindset I
was putting in so much effort and so
much focus that it it made me mentally
tougher so when I'm in the gym you know
doing a really grinding workout I had
this new this new feeling of strength in
me and this ability to push because I
believed in myself a little bit more
it's like an echo chamber isn't it yes
and it's not a tangible thing you have
to you have to do it and experience it
to really understand what I'm saying but
it made me a mentally stronger athlete
just by doing what I was told
yeah the slippery slope runs up and down
doesn't it when you brake when you brake
the discipline in one direction look at
what happens you've got a number you've
got a number of years of examples of
that and then when you break the
discipline in the opposite direction and
you start pushing beyond what you
thought was was capable then you benefit
exactly it's all about integrity you
know as a drug addict I had zero
integrity with myself so when I when I
would tell myself I want to accomplish X
goal I didn't believe it yeah because I
could not be trusted when I started to
do everything that I was told when I
started keeping promises to myself I
started to really believe in the things
that I was doing I started to really
believe in myself and workouts and it
was a very powerful experience
I agree H each step that you make is
built on top of the
previous one exactly do you think that
you would like to coach yourself if
you'd had the mic kazoo athlete in 2011
and you were the coach now do you think
that you would like to coach yourself as
an athlete I think I would actually
uh-huh at that at that time yes but by
the time I was on that team yes I was
very I would do anything that my coach
told me all of the all of the things in
and out of the gym and I think it would
have been it would have been fun for me
and intellectually stimulating to be
challenged so much because I always
wanted to know why we were doing what we
were doing not to not to call him out
and and argue with him but I just wanted
to understand I wanted to understand how
the body worked and how kinesiology
exercise science works so I think it
would have been fun for me yeah that's a
good question I love that yeah hunger
for information I guess that's laid the
foundations for you to be able to make
what is as far as I can see one of the
premier programming outfits that's in
the community at the moment so to give
you a little bit of information from my
side I started the Brut body program
what do we we start week five this week
five days I think so yeah one or two
today and I decided that at the
beginning of the year some friends have
given me some some really good feedback
on that and for anybody who's listening
who doesn't know what Brut body is it's
I would describe it and I might do this
wrongly as a physique focused CrossFit
program I suppose what's interesting for
me seeing someone who has been to the
pinnacle of the sport stood on the
podium twice at the CrossFit Games and
typically the I think physique and
aesthetics in CrossFit can be considered
a little bit of a dirty word sometimes I
think that Fitness comes first and the
over the tribalism that occurs between
the global side and the CrossFit side
sometimes means that if you see someone
who's doing bench press or is doing some
extra
girls in the gym you know that that's
very unlikely going to be for functional
reasons and I think it's really really
interesting to see you guys having set
up a program which is esthetics
conscious so let's fast forward and
let's talk about brute strength and what
you guys do and I can actually comment
on that absolutely because I think
that's a really interesting point and I
want to be clear that I so believe in
the CrossFit ethos and that and that
every human being should strive for
fitness at the same time brew body is
not meant to be done for one's lifetime
it's meant to be done for like three to
12 months some people will choose to do
it longer but it's it's to be done for a
short period of time and to teach you a
new way to train and to add to your
training vocabulary we've had so many
people that have been doing crossfit for
seven plus years that come in and say
i've never felt better or I've never
been this strong or I'm having so much
fun with all of these new movements so
it just it exposes people to things that
they're not already doing yeah and it
all of the accessory work in it has
amazing effects on people's bodies that
they're able to go back to their regular
you know CrossFit programming later and
then add in some of this stuff on the
side to keep themselves healthy to just
keep things spicy and entertaining and
exciting right isn't it isn't it
interesting that you've got people that
have been doing crossfit as a sport and
you're having to teach them things like
one and a quarter incline DB curls and
like Zurcher curls and stuff like that
like the typical approach to gym bro
lifting would be coming the other way it
would be I can do supinated bicep curls
and tricep tricep extensions for days
but I don't know how a clean-and-jerk I
don't know how a snatch yeah and I think
it speaks to the dominance of CrossFit
as a methodology and a functional
fitness that you can actually you can
you know teach people there's a you know
eight eight to 14
is an acceptable number of reps to try
and do right right and you yeah and you
may not do that every day yeah but
that's a great way to train sometimes I
think you can get some great adaptations
that way okay so I think from what's
interesting is that you see the guys in
the gym especially the CrossFit gym
we've got our gym in Newcastle is split
in half so there's one side that's the
global side and there's one side that's
the CrossFit side and I'm definitely
seeing an evolution I think of CrossFit
in that there is complete fluidity
between both mmm there's the guys that
tend to spend more time on one side and
tend spend more time on the other but
there is a lot more movement between the
two do you think moving forward that
we're going to see more of that do you
think that you can see CrossFit is who
are going to become increasingly focus
or less focused on being able to work
capacity and more focused on aesthetics
as the sport becomes more inclusive and
wider or do you still think that it's
all moving in the same direction and
it's kind of just extra arms and extra
extra armoury being added in to an
existing body of knowledge so to speak
it's an interesting question I think for
sure the only thing I know for sure is
that CrossFit coaches are becoming very
very competent they are there they are
learning all types of different
methodologies and so I think what we
will see is a lot of gyms with just a
lot more variety of movements and a lot
more variety of even methodologies but
right we might see people go through
different phases or we might just see a
lot of different movements that you're
you're not used to seeing mixed in your
training either before during or after
your workouts as far as the the camp
that people are a part of I think people
just love to be a part of a camp so I
think they're going to remain a little
bit divided so that they can call
themselves a meathead or call themselves
a hardcore crossfitter
people just love to feel sturdily a part
of a certain tribe of people I agree
no I couldn't agree
that identity the group identity that's
fed through from training method
methodology is absolutely correct
we've got Thursday nights at six o'clock
is Gun Club which night which is an hour
of unwrapped curls and superset
benchpress with a plank rows and stuff
like that and that's really really cool
and seen some of the guys eyes open up
if they come in and they've done they've
done bro lifting for a while and then
they come across to the CrossFit side
and they kind of suck everything pretty
much in the same way as everyone did and
then they see the Thursday six o'clock
class and they look at that and they
think I can actually this is this is my
jam again I can go in right I can show
everyone that I have all of this
training has been for something and it's
between 8 and 14 reps usually right and
through that I love that through that
experience you're able to have liked it
you're able to be on another level of
consciousness where you you all of a
sudden see okay
CrossFit may be like the best way but
you can also add in these other things
and it's not bad what's bad is it's
focusing solely on isolate isolation
exercises right that's just not that's
not a functional way to train your body
and it's not good for your health
long-term some isolation exercises
sprinkled into your programming can be a
phenomenal thing I agree
so moving forwards brute strength to me
it doesn't sound like it doesn't sound
like naturally you've had a massive
amount of opportunity to develop a
business acumen maybe apart from when
you're trying to negotiate the price of
drugs run in your life it doesn't seem
like you would be top of the list as
someone who would become a clever
businessman and will be able to move
forward very quickly with that so can
you explain about how you commercialized
your passion so I was really lucky to be
a part of the very first barbell shrug
mastermind and I went into that event
literally knowing nothing about business
and I'm not even I'm not exaggerating I
I was about to buy a gym from Tommy and
I was about to start Brut I knew both of
those were happening and I had
absolutely no idea what I was doing and
I went into that event knowing nothing
and I came out with just my mind
exploded with different ideas so first
off I was very lucky to have Mike
Bledsoe and Doug Larsen and those guys
as some mentors and they've continued to
mentor me throughout the years and I
think one of the biggest gifts I was
given and skills that I created through
my time in rehab was the ability to just
ask for help and not be afraid of
looking like I don't know anything
I have always but since I got out of
rehab I have just been such a sponge for
information and just always asking for
feedback asking how I'm doing where I
can improve what other people are doing
and just really being vulnerable in the
sense that some people might think some
people might think that's a that's a
sign of weakness or they they might
think I'm you know I really don't know
what I'm talking about and I'm fine with
that and it's allowed me to learn I had
a really rapid rapid rate and you know
steal a lot of ideas absolutely you know
what I mean one of one of my favorite
youtubers anyone who's listening y'all
know who I'm about to quote Jordan
Peterson one of his rules for life he's
got 40 rules for life
and one of them is assume the person you
are speaking to know something that you
don't and listen to them hard enough so
that they will tell you and I think that
that is so many of the things that we've
brought today number one is tell the
truth
number three is act in a way so that you
can tell the truth about your actions
and you know so many of the things that
we've gone through today principles that
appear to manifest themselves in
different walks of life it's interesting
that you say that you're showing
vulnerability now whereas the first
portion of your life where you were
struggling you were hyper owner of
unburnable or at least externally whilst
in are now in
so now speaking the truth forward
definitely appears to have done wonders
for yourself
so you know that brute barbell at the
time what was it what was the first
brand Bruce barbell Bruce barbell
yeah so my partner Matt Bruce yeah he
just had to have his name in there
somewhere and then in the rebrand and so
we combine Bruce with you to CrossFit
uh-huh brute cause you barbell might've
been as much as some people to pronounce
yeah right so why does it go from that
from right right when we started yeah oh
let's see we start we start programming
for people that want to compete in a
very very high level for crop in
CrossFit right and we've basically
exactly so we I start basically giving
people the type of programming that I
was given tailored to their weaknesses
somewhere along the way they actually
very quickly I learned the concept of in
business you don't really want to work
on your weaknesses instead you want to
highlight your strengths and then hire
people where you are weak and so I
started to create this team to come that
that really complemented me and so you
know I had people that paid attention to
detail people that were process oriented
people that could create systems
what are you that what are your
strengths and weaknesses in business my
strengths are getting ideas right making
making new ideas or taking an idea and
getting it started like rapidly fast
I don't need hardly any information to
you know to have the confidence to start
moving forward that's also a real big
problem sometimes because I don't quite
get enough information so my one of my
intentions this year is to take like a
sixty second pause before every decision
I make and I'm gonna be way more
accurate because of that yeah
what some of my weaknesses are it's
really painful for me to pay attention
to any level of detail I hate that I
hate doing anything more than once
I hate repetitive tasks those those are
by far the biggest oh and an
organization in general it's real it
takes me a lot of energy to keep
schedules in place and and different
people in place and managing people
those are those are just not in my
wheelhouse and so over time we just
hired people that love to do it and are
great at it yeah it's weird isn't it
because the same way as a football team
or a CrossFit team needs guys who bring
different strengths of weaknesses in you
know you can be even more specific with
business and have such a type mandate
for a particular a particular employee
or business partner to look after and
exactly I think I'll you really correct
doubling down on these strengths in any
sort of commercial pursuit it's the best
way to do it because being OK at
everything means that you're not really
very great to anything and right loads
of people out there that aren't
tremendously great or anything but
there's very few people that are
particularly great at something so I
think you've definitely stumbled across
something that is a really common route
to business success there so you're now
dealing with I wouldn't like to guess
how many clients globally it'll be tens
of countries thousands of clients and
you're now dealing with some of the best
athletes in the planet as well so we're
talking about hypertrophy based training
where you're taking people who maybe
just want to look better and then you're
also taking people to the games as well
right exactly for sure so you're going
from bottom to top can you name some of
the top level athletes that you're
working with at the moment we work with
Jacob Hebner Brooke ence Cara Webb
Christine and Dolly George Sanchez
Adrian Conway who was on my team we had
a we had the winning team from last year
the Wasatch brutes yep so those are some
of our heavy hitters some big name
yeah so one thing I wanted to move on to
was I've heard you talk an awful lot
about you hitting rock bottom allowed
you to spring back out in terms of your
development and your motivation I think
the people who hit absolute rock bottom
oh by the by the very definition they
are in them in the minority there's a
lot more people who are wallowing around
in this kind of two thirds bottom of a
squat so to speak to use the squat
analogy and we all know that if you're
there it's a lot more difficult to
spring back out because the the
beginning energy that it takes for you
to see everything has gone this is a
real life-changing epiphany moment
allowed you to say right this is enough
I'm knocking it on their heads are there
any things that you think that any
principles are any advice that you think
you could give to people who maybe don't
have it that bad but also kind of don't
have it that good does that make sense
that it's a little bit of a no-man's
land where it's not bad enough to make
it super bad to spring you back out at
the bottom but it's also nowhere near
really where you want to be and there
might be people who suffer with
depression a couple of days a month and
they have an anxiety and they have
problems that are left unchecked well
it's not chronic severe life stopping
they're not in an extreme amount of pain
that almost forces them to change I
totally get that survival mode yeah yeah
unfortunately a lot of those people they
they aren't even aware that they're in
any pain and so they're not even gonna
hear this but it's all it's really all
relative like I could have gone so much
deeper and so much further I could have
kept digging kept digging kept digging
the best way to get out of a hole the
first step is to literally just put down
the shovel right stop digging further
and decide that you want to change for
the for the people that just aren't
stoked about their life right maybe
they're a little bit sad maybe they're a
lot sad but
thing horrible is going on you're
literally your life is at stake right
now you have you know maybe 60 years
left 70 years left and then it's just
all done and you're not gonna have
another chance and so you're your entire
life is at stake and the only way that
you're going to have a positive
experience in your one chance on earth
is if you take a massive action towards
a different type of existence so first
off identify and accept that you are in
a place you don't want to be and realize
that that acceptance is not weakness is
actually courage and even vocalizing
that is is Kurt is courageous because
you're letting people see the the real
you and that's uh that's just an act of
courage yeah so first off reframe it
from a sign of weakness to a sign of
courage and then a couple helpful things
are don't be afraid to ask for help ask
you know if you if you see a person
living the life you want to live asking
them what the the basic principles the
most important principles are to follow
that that they use in their life and
then just focus on trying to know
yourself better and better through
becoming more self-aware you're you're
going to intuitively know what the right
decisions are for you and it takes it
takes time it takes consistency and it
takes hard work to really know what's
underneath all of the all of the layers
and the ways the defense mechanisms that
we absolutely cultivated over the years
but it's possibly the most important
work that we can possibly do well you've
only got that one life right and I don't
yeah one of the one of the big things I
think that to come out of this is taking
responsibility for your actions I think
that you do have two choices you can
presume that nothing you do matters and
that every decision that you make is
whether there's someone watching others
someone
not whether the coach in front is in
front of you or whether the coach isn't
even there on your training on your own
whether you're in rehab or out of rehab
however it might be that the decision is
ultimately meaningless or the
alternative that's good right because it
means well I don't have to take
responsibility for anything I guess
that's quite a that's not a tremendously
bad price to pay but the alternative is
everything you do matters every single
decision that you make whether you make
your bed or you don't make you bet
whether you wash the dishes up or you
don't wash the dishes up whether you
keep a promise to yourself or someone
else or whether you break it and I think
that the echo chamber the self
referential building one brick at a time
mentality that you've definitely had and
appears to have worked in you know
bounds for yourself
certainly it's certainly an inspiring
story for other people to hear and I
know that like you say it is all
relative and for someone to hear this
kind of a story and think well that's
not me I don't have it that bad
you know if it's not wouldn't believe
would be good then it can be better if
it's not absolutely perfect and there's
more work to be done and I think that
hopefully some people will hear and
think well actually yeah I could I could
make that bit over there that bit of my
life doesn't need a little bit of work I
shouldn't leave it by the wayside so the
what I want to finish with is some
discussion on meditation and I've heard
you talk about it for a while and I'd be
really interested to know what your
typical practice is at the moment super
super simple I sit down in a chair I
said a 20 minute timer and I focus on my
breath every single time I catch myself
lost in thought I just bring myself back
to my breath
that's my sitting meditation practice
and I've been really really consistent
with it for a while now and what I've
noticed more than ever and I've had this
insight over the years but I'm really
I'm seeing this on a very frequent basis
now where I am just the watcher of my
thoughts and the watcher of my feelings
rather
than being my thoughts and being my
feelings so somebody cuts me off in
traffic my untrained mind I am just
immediately pissed I may be thrown the
bird I speed up I you know I get in
front of him and slam on the brakes I am
just I am angry right through the
consistent practice of meditation I've
come to understand that the real me is
just the watcher of those things and if
I can develop the in in the more I am I
am that watcher the better my life is
right the more I have the choice of
which thought to believe and and I have
control over my thoughts and my feelings
so it basically creates like the
circumstances in our lives don't change
they're going to happen to us right
that's just life but what happens in
between the time that that circumstance
happens and you have a thought that's
where the magic is and consistent
meditation can create this gap between
the circumstance and the thought and the
bigger that gap the more choice you have
so it goes circumstance happens in life
triggers a thought triggers an emotion
triggers a behavior and gives you a
result that results at the end is always
directly related to that original
thought that you have so if you have a
result that you keep getting in life
that you're not happy with then reverse
engineer it figure out a thought that
you need to think to trigger the right
emotion and behavior and then result and
then notice that you you're just in
control of which thoughts you believe
right what one thought in relation to
getting cut off in traffic is that
[ __ ] is such an [ __ ] like he
probably does that to every person I've
got to teach him a lesson
yeah that that is believable like that
could that could be the case right
Alleva but not beneficial right one that
serves me is something like man like
that kind of pissed me off but he's
probably having a bad day I
really have no idea what's going on in
his life maybe he's actually in the
middle of an emergency that triggers a
very different type of emotion which
triggers a different behavior which
results in me just chilling having a
good day yep
no I couldn't we we're we have access to
that in every single area of our lives
so you're doing at the moment mostly one
guided meditation yeah all all unguided
have you done any formal practice have
you gone away and been coached by anyone
or ever had a meditation teacher yes
I've done a lot of different a lot of
different things with teachers I've done
actually a lot of guided meditations I
did headspace for a long time and I
think for beginners
that's hands down or the best way to
learn oh babe it's fun it's phenomenal
it's very cheap and it and it's the most
kind of like compassionate way to learn
right we're using that where you don't
beat yourself up for being quote unquote
bad at meditation yeah he takes that
away from you Andy is the nicest guy
ever that voice is the most comforting
thing I actually bought my mom a year of
headspace yesterday it's nice her
birthday's not for like two months but
she managed to download the app I've got
no idea how because as I write her iPod
usually defeats it but yes here she
managed to download the app and had done
the ten day and I was like right you've
got you've gone this far like I'm gonna
get you the rest of it I'm at Carl I
mentioned this on one of the life hacks
podcasts that we did but you might be
interested as well Aubry Marcus who
won't on it mmm he has a fantastic
guided meditation series and it's
complete with binaural beats then come
along with it and that course is called
release into now in its six weeks half
an hour a day and some of the stuff that
he does in there so you're talking about
detachment from thoughts and watching
the watcher there's an exercise in that
where he asks you to visualize a video
camera three feet away and two feet up
in the air and then you watch yourself
through the video camera the inside
reduces to leave the outline of the body
and then the outline of the body reduces
to leave nothing and that exercise
that's only on week two and that
exercise
was so difficult to do it's a very
different kind of meditation it's not
emptying the mind it's very focused so
rather than it being floodlight it's
spotlight borne some of the some of the
ways of thinking that that developed me
that forced me to develop were the way
that you feel after doing those is very
very distinct in the same way that I'd
say working up to a 1 rep max back squat
is very distinct from going and running
a 10k right it's still physically exact
fascinating really check it out you
should do it's really really interesting
so I think the meditation side of stuff
definitely appears to match in with your
desire for bettering yourself all the
time and I think it's it's really
inspiring to hear a story from someone I
said this to Dom you hear this all the
time from people in the news that too
much too soon
and the stories of people who go from
rock bottom and do manage to make it to
a place where they feel valued but to
hear it firsthand from somebody who is
part of a community do you still do
still coach you coach at a box or are
you I don't I don't I travel too much to
commit to coaching in person and I
actually don't coach anyone remotely
anymore as well okay we have we have
coaches for all of our programs now okay
do you miss up a part of me does for
sure and I think I'll probably revisit
I'll probably go back to it at some
point in my life but I feel really
energized and challenged by working on
the business rather rather than working
in the business as much yeah and so I'm
I'm just really enjoying it for now well
there's only 24 hours in your day but
when I'm when you write a program that
can be distributed by however many
coaches that can reach more people right
rap just to finish I want right in
saying that you compete in the open last
year was that the first time in a little
while it was it was the first so I had a
I had back surgery in 2013 I had a
lumbar fusion done and I thought I was
done forever and then this past year I
started going to this really kick-ass
gym called CrossFit your car whoo just
phenomenal competitive environment and
they it really just fired me up so I
started in January and I went to their
level two class so they have three
levels that they're level two is like
sport which is a like a regular CrossFit
class and then level three is like your
competitor class I just wanted to do to
do regular CrossFit classes and I went
that went in there and just went all out
and I ended up getting in really really
good shape for me right relative to my
best and I decided to compete in the
open and ended up doing really well
you came 327 was it 3 top 300 I'm not
sure in the in the world but I got like
19th in the region yeah so having had a
disc fusion in your back and that was
the reason that you exited sort of full
competitive CrossFit a few years ago and
you still managed to get so high up the
rankings in the open I mean does that
tempt you do you do you hear the the
CrossFit do you hear Dave Castro on your
shoulder just sort of teasing you to
come back definitely definitely it's
very very tempting but I had this really
powerful realization a few months ago
that the only reason I still want to
stick around and compete is because I
think other people will like it and I
will get attention for it I really am
not passionate about competing in
CrossFit anymore I love I love doing the
regular CrossFit classes with you know
with a like a big mixture of people yeah
just like I started doing in the
beginning but I just lost a passion for
competing so and at the same time I've
been really really wanting to get into
jiu-jitsu and kind of like dipping my
toes in the past few years and just not
sticking to it because I keep kind of
getting back into CrossFit yeah and so
I've decided this year I'm not gonna do
the open I'm going to put my ego aside
and not go for that thing that I know
I'll get
my ego stroked you're gonna do well it
right and you're gonna and it's almost
definitely you're gonna suck at jujitsu
exactly exactly and by making that I
haven't been more proud of a decision in
a while because it's really it really is
so tempting to want to do that thing
that I think people really like yeah you
know and I'm gonna suck at jujitsu for a
long time I might never be good at it
but I really love it and I love the
feeling of striving for mastery and I
just kinda lost that in CrossFit and so
now I'm just using CrossFit as a way to
stay in great shape and just getting
passionate about this new thing
fantastic
Michael I've really really enjoyed this
man can you tell us where we can find
you online you can find me our website
is brute strength training com
I am completely off of all social media
for the time being so you won't find me
there that's really interesting why is
that yeah uh I recently read a book
called deep work by Cal Newport yeah we
heard of it yes I've have you read it
yep you know for the listeners it
basically explains that most of us spend
maybe all of our time if not the vast
majority of our time spent in shallow
work which is not cognitively demanding
not very meaningful work and although I
wasn't spending a significant amount of
time over the course of a week and I
tracked it I wasn't spending that much
time on social media but I was spending
it in the times where I was getting
uncomfortable and I was starting to do
deep work and I would just just want to
distract myself full butt right again
yeah so when I was like like really
getting into preparing for a really big
podcast or I was writing an article for
a manual that we were working on I just
found myself wanting to distract and I I
don't like feeling controlled by social
media I also realize that I don't really
use it for much positive I don't post
much we have a social media team that
does our social media for the company I
was
posting much personally and I was just
spending my time looking at people and
kind of feeling shitty about myself
because I'm seeing all of the best of
everyone's week or everyone's day and I
could always find someone in one like
social media session that I could I
could say oh my god he or she is better
than me yeah and I would if I would
really like it wouldn't be anything
significant but it would be this little
sting of I'm not doing enough or he or
she is better than me and I found myself
we're like kind of wishing not wishing
poor poor absolutely the word it's
difficult don't want people to succeed
yet I don't like that that's country
that's country to what we've literally
just discussed we're talking about
compassion virtue integrity wanting the
best for everybody else and exactly in
the same hand it's so strange that on
your footnote for this podcast that
we've stumbled upon this so I did ten
minutes Dom from social chain these guys
have 400 million reach on social media
which is a significant proportion of the
globe right and I asked him about the
ethics of Technology about whether or
not he feels that people need to be more
mindful with the use of tech I'm not
sure if you have to know that you're a
fan of Sam Harris
do you follow his podcast I don't man
I'm going to get into it so episode I
think it's episode 71 I keep on drilling
this I promise I'm not on a referral
code for some I respond yes boring
Tristan Harris from time well-spent
this podcast basically talks about how
cognitive biases and persuasion
techniques are used by companies like
Twitter and Google and Facebook and
Instagram the dopamine release the
reason that candy crush was so
successful all of that sort of stuff and
you've stumbled across everything there
the fact of the matter is that on social
media we see the best of everybody
else's lives yeah whilst only in our
eyes through a lens of resentment and
complete awareness of our own cowardice
and stupidity on a daily basis we only
get to see the worst of our own we
compare the best everyone else's lives
with the worst of our own and it
inevitably leads to feelings
we track the wrong things absolutely if
you do get back on your phone download
an app called moment which will try have
it you've got it that's all you know so
it's Tristan you when you listen that
podcast you will you will calanque
you will thank the fact that you decided
to put the phone down and I think so
interesting that that's something that
you've come across I've also got man and
I do wanna I do want to note that I
don't judge anyone for using it I just
realized that for me it wasn't serving
me right and I want to regain control I
want to be more mindful in my life and
what I've what I've noticed is that I am
significantly more present in every
single thing that I do because I don't
have you know I could open I could open
my email or open Google but there's not
that many like fun things that I want to
go do on my phone anymore right so I
don't I spend like like a tenth of the
time on there it's awesome what's the
strategy if you just gone up free have
you just deleted everything it's social
media app free yep yeah yep
so nothing except for stuff that you
need to work and I message and what's up
and stuff like that exactly and I'm very
I'm not perfect with this but I am
careful about when I when I check and
respond to email and I try to do it in
Windows throughout the day so even even
email is limited fantastic well I've got
coming up soon I've got this CEO of the
light phone calm which is a really
interesting device which is discussed by
Tristana and he basically it's a phone
which allows you to call nine numbers
and it forwards on him it forwards on
from your other phone it tells you the
time and who's ringing you if they ring
you don't need a new SIM card you don't
need anything you leave your phone at
home and you take that one out and it's
if you're doing a weekend away with the
family it'll last for four days because
it doesn't do and yeah I think mindful
tactical mindful tech is definitely
going to be an emerging field I think
it's really really cool that you're
you've stumbled upon it yourself I think
that's that's yeah that's definitely
very admirable so we got halfway through
you saying what your Instagram
is that you will check at some point in
the future probably yeah probably but
the but as it says in the book if
nothing bad happens as a result of you
stopping just stop altogether but it's
it's my full name it's at Michael cashew
that's CA za y OU u X send me a direct
message if I if I open it and there's a
bunch of them I'll probably answer them
all you can you can also find my wife's
company at working against gravity I am
also a team member on that company as
well that's a nutrition consulting
company fantastic Mike thank you so much
for your time I really appreciate it
dude good luck with you Jiu Jitsu as you
chase thank you for our next few weeks
and good luck to your athletes as well I
appreciate them in season yeah this is a
real pleasure I love how how
conversational it is and how you just go
deep it's awesome thank you very much
cheers dude
[Music]